Spanish Moss is neither Spanish nor moss. Buckle
up for this one. Usually, in a situation like
this, we have like the sort of scientific botany
names to help us out. But the Latin name for this
literally translates to resembling a lichen.
Like a lichen is like just moss’s cousin. But
guess what? It's not a lichen either. It turns out
Spanish moss is a flowering plant, and it's in the
same family as pineapples. It grows mostly in the
Southeast United States and in South America. And
it's actually a really dope plant that makes these
trees look amazing. It gets all its nutrients from
the air and from water. Doesn't even have any
roots. So why is it called Spanish moss? Well,
the French. French colonizers. They actually
called it “Spanish beard” for a while because
it reminded them of, well, the beards of
Spanish men. But honestly, my favorite name
is the one that the indigenous Americans gave
to Spanish moss, which was “tree hair,” because